alright hey everyone I propose we get
started the first bake-off has begun you
should have gotten an email from Piazza
I think I'll just go through my posting
really quickly in case any questions
arise I think it's straightforward but
let's just make sure everyone is clear
on this because the time window is tight
you just have until Wednesday at 4:30 so
here's the procedure the test data are
at this link so download that and unzip
it and then move the whole directory
into your word SIM data directory
whatever you have set forward sim home
in the homework notebook it's probably
just data word sim so move the data in
there so your system can find it that's
step one and note this move the
directory not just its contents unless
you want to have to fiddle with this
reader code then open your completed
homework 1 notebook you should have
already submitted that but now you're
gonna add to it find the cell near the
bottom that begins with enter your
bake-off assessment code into this cell
let's call that the bake-off cell and
then you're just paste in this blob of
code here it's just two new readers you
can tell that these data sets are the
MTurk 287 data set which I think in this
literature is thought of as a
relatedness data set and sim Lex $9.99
which i think is a similarity data set
so if your own model favored one or the
other kind of problem
well it's evenly matched here because
we're gonna macro average the score from
these two test data sets and you can see
here I've gathered the two readers into
this tuple called bake-off so that's
step one now let's suppose that the
custom model you developed for her you
know for part four let's suppose you
called that data frame custom DF then
all you have to do is in the bake off
cell at the at the very bottom so it
prints out enter this code where custom
DF is the model that you're evaluating
crucially you have to set the readers
argument to bake off so that you don't
use the development data for this and
then optionally if you feel your model
needs to be evaluated with a specific
distance function you should specify
that as well otherwise it's going to
default to cosine which might be fine
for you but maybe this is an important
design choice for your model so then you
just run that bake-off cell and this is
important right so we're all on the
honor code here running the cell more
than once with different choices for
custom D F is against the rules that is
dishonest the idea is that you have
completed development and now on
completely fresh data you are seeing how
that system works so if you go back and
make an adjustment to custom D F and try
again as soon as you do that you've
broken the rules okay we don't have a
way to really check this but that's the
way the field works and it no progress
kind of depends on people being
responsible about this so run that code
once and then to help us see whether we
can reproduce your the results that you
got in the cell right below that this is
step 5 just enter the macro average
score that you got so that we can if we
rerun your system compare against that
and maybe contact you if there's a big
discrepancy or something having done
that you just upload the notebook to
canvas and if your system as in the
homework one if it depends on external
code or data you know things that won't
be in our course environments then put
it in a zip archive and upload that as
well and then you're done you have to do
that by Wednesday at 4:30 we're gonna
look at a bunch of the systems and we
hope to announce the results next Monday
certainly next Wednesday I think it
should be straightforward I think it
should be really rewarding to see what
happened with your systems any questions
or concerns all right we have officially
begun bake-off 1 now we want to switch
gears the topic for this week is
supervised sentiment analysis I'm gonna
try to do a bunch of things with this
unit so as you can tell from this
overview here and by the way the slides
are posted so feel free to download them
and as before they include a bunch of
code snippets that I think will be
useful for you in terms of taking the
material and turning it into code that
you can use for your homework and for
your bake-off submission and a
I'm going to leave some time at the end
of the day today to introduce the next
bake-off and the homework so that you
guys feel like you can get started right
away on these problems well I'm going to
be trying to do for these two lectures
is first of all introduce sentiment to
you in a kind of general way because I
think it can be a wonderful source of
projects there's lots of great data and
I'm going to argue for you that I think
the sentiment challenge is a deep NLU
challenge some people regard it as kind
of superficial but I think with some
serious thought about this we can see
that this is a kind of microcosm for
everything in NL you then I want to give
you some general practical tips that are
kind of outside of the code base but
illuminating I think about how to design
effective systems for sentiment but
actually for lots of problems then we
get down to the nitty-gritty I'm going
to introduce the Stanford sentiment
treebank wisk which is kind of our core
data set for this unit that should be
pretty fast the main thing that I want
to do with you is make sure you feel
comfortable working with this code in
Fort here SST Pi which is a module that
is included in the course repo and it
plays the role of VSM pie in the
previous unit it's got like a lot of
functions that I'm going to ask you to
use for the homework and for the
bake-off and frankly also my claim is
that it represents a lot of good
practices around designing experiments
especially in situations where you might
want to try lots of systems and lots of
variants of systems which is you know
par for the course in lots of types of
machine learning having done that I
think we won't get through that all that
today but I hope to at least get to four
for Wednesday we'll talk about methods
and then we're going to kind of dive
into different model choices you might
make so feature functions you could
write if you're dealing with kind of
linear classifiers and then we'll look
at R and n classifiers and tree
structured networks which are more
modern and maybe more successful
approaches to sentiment and this is a
nice topic because sentiment is great
but it's also a chance for us to kind of
get some common ground build up a
foundation around best practices for
supervised to NLP problems that is
something I'm trying to do in parallel
with you so question
you have about methods metrics models
all that stuff should be on the table
we're kind of using sentiment as a
chance to introduce all of that okay The
Associated materials this is a small
typo that should be too
but just to review so this is the core
code and then there are three notebooks
the first one is an overview to the SST
I'm going to kind of give a look at that
today the second one is more traditional
approaches to supervised sentiment or
supervised learning in general I've
called that hand-built features because
I think that's their characteristic and
then the third one oh that's also type
well I'm embarrassed that should be SST
the third one is neural approaches so
the RN ends and the trees but also kind
of intermediate models that use glove
type representations distributed
representations as the input to
traditional linear classifiers it's a
kind of nice progression of ideas and
then the homework two and bake-off two
are paired in that notebook the core
reading is this paper by Souter at all
that introduced the SSD and also
introduced a lot of very powerful tree
structured networks for the problem and
then I would suggest as auxiliary to
reading so if you want to just learn
about sentiment this pang and leafing is
great it's a kind of compendium of ideas
for sentiment analysis and then Goldberg
2015 that's different that is a really
nice primer for doing deep learning in
NLP it it kind of unifies in notation
and in concepts a lot of the models that
you'll encounter if you need a further
review of kind of more basic supervised
learning stuff then check the website I
provided a few links to different online
tutorials and stuff that would be like
one level back on linear classifiers and
things which I'm kind of taking for
granted in here let's start with the
conceptual challenges I said that
sentiment was a deep problem sometimes
people think of it as kind of
superficial I want to claim different so
just as an exercise let's ask ourselves
the question which of the following
sentences Express sentiment and what is
the sentiment polarity positive or
negative if any
there was an earthquake in California it
sounds like bad news
maybe unless you're a seismologist who
was safely out of the state does it have
negative sentiment you know this is a
kind of edge case in the sense that you
might depending on how you phrase the
problem to the people doing annotation
they might say yes they might say no
it's worth reflecting on right but to
give an answer of yes this is sentiment
and it's negative you need to bring in a
lot of other assumptions the team failed
to complete the physical challenge
negative or positive sentiment what do
you think first of all is it a sentiment
relevant statement or is it neutral I
guess you could ask that primary
question and the secondary question is
it positive or negative well that would
probably depend on what the team
referred to and what your perspective
was and I feel like if we know that it's
another team this is clearly bad news
maybe we give that negative sentiment
maybe not maybe we exempt the whole
thing again this could be a point of
unclarity they said it would be great
this seems clearly to involve some kind
of evaluative sentiment right but it is
arguably not the sentiment necessarily
of the person or the the author or the
speaker so is it positive or negative
it feels like it's positive with respect
to some other agent but as you can see
from these continuations they said it
would be great and they were right that
seems clearly positive right by my
normal definitions but they said it
would be great and they were wrong that
seems more like negative sentiment right
and the nuance there is that in this
case for the first sentence we need to
know not only that the adjective great
was used but that it was used in the
context of this verb of saying and verbs
of saying do not necessarily commit the
author to their content right they're
just reporting other facts they might
create a certain bias but it's only
until we get to the second sentence that
we kind of know how to resolve the
sentiment here what about this one the
party fat cap
the party fat cats are sipping their
expensive imported wines negative or
positive effect it sounds kind of
negative to me it sounds like it's you
know playing a role doing a little
mimicry the challenge here would be that
there's a lot of positive words in that
sentence so your system is apt to
misapprehend the sentiment here is
positive when in fact the vibe that I
get is pretty negative so again like
perspective is creeping in what about oh
you're terrible I think that would
really depend on the context on the face
of it it sounds quite negative it sounds
like an accusation but if it's a couple
of friends kind of teasing each other
about a joke or something then it could
be endearing right and it would be hard
to classify maybe the whole point of
this little bit of negativity is to
create a positive social bond in which
case calling it negative is really to
miss the point
there's a lot of this stuff here's to
you you bastard that sounds really
negative but that could be very
affectionate in the right kind of
context right this is a real snippet
from a review of the movie 2001 I'm sure
we have some 2001 fans in here this is a
classic movie that is also very long and
let's face it at times very boring many
consider the masterpiece but will during
boring slow-moving or annoying that has
a lot of negative stuff in it but you
can probably intuit that the author of
this sentence likes this movie like this
is probably embedded in a positive
review not for sure but that kind of
seems to be it seems like they're
building up some kind of expectation
that they're going to then kind of
thwart right so again very complicated
perspective fact and let's also just
round this out by thinking about all the
complicated ways that we as human beings
can be related to products and people
and events and so forth think about
long-suffering fans who liked the first
album but feel like all the other ones
were sellouts their negative effect is
going to have a whole lot of complexity
to it that isn't just like I dislike
this new album or what about bittersweet
memories or hilariously embarrassing
right it seems off to just say that
these things are positive or negative
there's just a whole lot of other
dimensions here and so my my summary of
that would be positive negative is one
dimension that's important but there's
lots of other aspects to sentiment
analysis if you think more generally
about kind of effective computing make
sense I guess part of the lesson here is
be careful how you define the problem
and the other lesson here is that you
could make this problem kind of
endlessly deep
here's another perspective on this is
actually work that I do with more atsuta
off one of the teaching team a while ago
this is actually from a network a sorry
a data set of people transitioning from
one mood to another they would give kind
of mood updates on a social network
platform and there are two interesting
things about this first of all the
number of kind of moods that people are
in is astoundingly high and also the
kind of ways in which they relate to
each other and are differentiated is
also fascinating and you start to see
really quickly that standard things like
positive negative or maybe like emphatic
or attenuating those are just two of
many dimensions and then the other part
about this since it's a transition
diagram is that you can see that people
are likely to transition in and around
certain sub parts of this emotional
space and less likely to transfer across
to certain other parts and it kind of
gives a picture of the contours of our
emotional lives but it also shows you
just how high dimensional this problem
could be unfortunately we're gonna look
at just positive negative sentiment but
there are data sets out there in ways of
thinking about the problem that would
embrace much more of this nuanced final
thing about this because one thing you
might do and actually bill set us up for
this on the first day is think about
applying your sentiment analysis system
in the real world and my my pitch to you
there would be you'll encounter many
people in the business world who think
they want pie charts like this this is
my imagination about what it's like to
be a business leader in q1 the negative
effect was 30 and in q2 it's 35 maybe
that's an interest
lead right to see that this breakdown in
your reviews or whatever your social
media updates are trending negative but
the thing of this is is it's very
unlikely that that answers the question
that they have probably even if this was
estimated correctly what they really
want to know is why and one exciting
thing to think about is how you could
take an NLU system that could do this
basic thing and offer much more of that
why question because after all the why
answer is latent in these texts that
you're analyzing and your capacity or
your system's capacity to just label
them as positive or negative it's just
like the thin thinnest slice of what you
could actually be doing with that text
and so immediately you could think about
branching out and going deeper and I
think we're now at a state in nlu way
where we could think seriously about
answering those why questions one more
thing about this by way of general setup
so we're gonna have to be pretty narrow
talking about the Senate Stanford
sentiment treebank
but there are lots of other kind of
tasks or areas within NLU that are
adjacent to sentiment that I think are
really interesting to address we won't
have time for all of them but what I did
here is list out a whole bunch that I
could think of and then for each one I
listed a paper that I think would be a
great starting point obviously each one
of these things has a huge literature
associated with it so I had to be kind
of subjective and selective but what I
tried to do is pick papers that either
are just great about giving you a
picture of the landscape of ideas or
even better that have associated public
data that you could get started on right
away I've really actually tried to favor
papers that have a data set associated
with them and it's not that I'm saying
that these problems are the same as
sentiment I think they're actually very
different even the ones that might
superficially look like sentiment like
hate speech but rather people tend to
think about them together and I do think
a lot of the methods that we discuss
transfer Pibb pretty nicely into these
new domains especially if you're willing
to do the work of really thinking deeply
about what these problems are like in
the way that I'm encouraging us to do
for sentiment here
and this is not an exhaustive list I
just thought these are really exciting
problems to work on questions or
comments about that a general set up or
about sentiment analysis in general yeah
figure out why I think you're already on
the right track right take this review
that has four stars associated with it
and see if we can get down to the level
of which aspects are being highlighted
maybe some of them are negative there
are some datasets that give you that
kind of multi aspect sentiment but it
might be a kind of latent variable that
you want to try to induce with some
uncertainty yeah it's a great question
how about some general practical tips I
think these are interesting they don't
necessarily apply to the SST because if
it's unique characteristics but this is
good stuff to know about in general I
claim first some selected sentiment
datasets that we won't get to look at
here's a whole mess of them what I've
tried to do actually is favor either
datasets that are massive like the two
amazon ones one release by Amazon and
one by McCauley who is a postdoc here
those are both truly enormous and offer
breakdowns by product and by user and
some other interesting metadata so that
you could use them to do some sentiment
analysis that also brought in other kind
of contextual predictors and you could
certainly work at scale like if you
wanted to build your own word
representations the way we did in the
first unit as the foundation for your
project these datasets would support
that which I think is very exciting and
rapiers also like that also really large
Bingley Yu has released tons of datasets
about sentiment and they range from just
like you know 30 million reviews up from
Amazon that he got somehow on down to
kind of what you working into them which
is like annotations at the level of
aspects of cameras so you could do much
more
grayned work with andrew moss i released
a data set up here that gets a lot of
use this might be a good kind of
development data set for you it's pretty
big it's got a mess of reviews that are
unlabeled for developing unsupervised
representations and I think it's a
pretty easy problem as they go well also
this one is different so I was involved
with this work as well
sentiment and social networks together I
think this is a really exciting
extension and if you've done work on
kind of like social network graphs or
knowledge graphs it's really cool to
think about combining them with textual
sentiment analysis we did that in that
paper there West at all and we released
a data set of people who are running for
office on Wikipedia and all those
discussions are public and a lot of them
are evaluative and so we have this
network of people and we also have all
these evaluative texts and we brought
them together and then finally the SST
is one we're going to look at you have
other greatest hits in mind datasets you
work with for sentiment this isn't
exhaustive I just thought these were
cool ones basically they're also a lot
of sentiment lexico and these can be
useful resources for you it actually
these could be used for problems related
to the SST so I thought I would just
highlight them here bingley use opinion
lexicon is just two wordless
positive-negative you're gonna work with
it on homework one because it's built
into NLT k and it's really nice in the
sense that it does a good job of
classifying words in a pretty context
independent way and it's pretty well
attuned to the kind of data that you
might see on the web centi wordnet is a
project of adding sentiment information
to wordnet and so if you're already
doing work in wordnet it's a kind of
nice counterpart and NLT kay has a sin T
word net reader which actually I wrote
the NP QA subjectivity lexicon is a kind
of classic and if you follow that link
you'll see that that group released a
bunch of datasets related to sentiment
the Harvard General Inquirer is just a
huge spreadsheet of words along the rows
and then lots of different effective and
other social dimension measured along
the columns
almost like a vector space that's been
hand curated and it's used a lot in the
field
Luke is similar linguistic in Korean
word counts although you kind of have to
pay for Luke but so if you don't want to
fork over whatever they're charging you
could just use the Harvard Enquirer and
then I listed to others Hamilton at all
well Hamilton was a student in the NLP
group here and he released these
datasets called social sent and that's
really cool because that's not only some
lexico but also some methods for
developing context-sensitive sentiment
lexicon so that you could learn like the
sentiment words that are associated with
music and with cooking and so forth and
there's lots of nuance there so I find
that very exciting and then finally this
is just a big human developed so human
annotated it's kind of like an
experiment a huge lexicon of scores for
different words along a few different
affective dimensions and I've worked
very successfully with this final one in
the past I think I won't spend too much
time on it but I do have this slide here
that shows that for those classic lexico
what kind of what their relationships
are like so that you could figure out
whether or not it's worth bringing to
over them in or you could concentrate on
just one and I've done that by
quantifying not only their overlap but
also the number of places where they
disagree on sentiment I think I won't
dive into this but it's there for you as
a resource if you decide that you're
going to bring these things into your
systems let's do a few nuts and bolts
things too the first one I wanted to
start with is just tokenization because
I think people tend to default to
default tokenizer z' and sentiment is an
area where you can see that that might
be a mistake so here's my argument for
that I've started with this imaginary
tweet NL Ewers can't wait for the June 9
projects yay and that has an emoticon
that's gotten garbled and then a link to
our class site so the first thing you
might want to do as a pre-processing
step is fix up the HTML entities that
are in there so that it looks better and
so that you can recover this emoticon
but this step here it's very common to
encounter text like this and you might
want to check to see whether it's worth
fixing those up
so if I've done that then I have this
text here if I apply just a whitespace
tokenizer it does okay in the sense that
it has preserved the emoticon because it
was written in a kind of cooperative way
over here with a white space around it
it didn't quite identify the username
because it has a colon stuck to it it
did well on these tokens it didn't do
well on the date and it didn't do well
in the URL because it left that period
attached so this is maybe not the best
the treebank tokenizer this is the one
that you will likely encounter other
systems using it's by far the most
pervasive tokenizer just about any
large-scale NLP project has this step
under the hood and this is a really
meaningful choice because it comes from
a different era and you can see that it
has really made a hash of this text so
it took the username and split off the @
it divided up the contractions so that
the negation is separate that might be
good for you it might not be it broke
apart the hash tag which again it could
hashtag czar different on Twitter and
certainly different for sentiments so
you might want to preserve them as
distinct tokens it broke apart all this
stuff maybe that's okay and it also
destroyed the emoticon it turned that
into a just a list of punctuation and
then it also destroyed the URL so if you
think about using your text that you
know text that you're going to find on
Twitter this is probably a pretty
dangerous movement it's certainly not
going to allow you to find the emoticons
or travel around in the links that
people have provided or do any
aggregation by hashtag or username so
this is maybe not the best and that kind
of queues up a bunch of stuff that we
might want from a sentiment aware
tokenizer right it should preserve
emoticons it should preserve kind of
social media markup you might also
wanted to preserve some of the
underlying markup it's meaningful for
example that people have wrapped some
words in the strong tag for example to
indicate that they were in bold might
want to do something with people
curse words because those are certainly
socially meaningful you could think
about preserving capitalization where
it's meaningful right it's one thing to
write great and another thing to do it
in all caps more advanced thing would be
like regularizing the lengthening so
that when people do why and then just
hold down the a key and then why to
indicate real emotional involvement
where the longer they held down the key
the more involved they are you know all
those things are just going to be very
sparse tokens and if you could normalize
them to like three repeats then you
might get a meaningful signal from them
and then you could think even further
down the line about capturing some multi
word expressions that how sentiment like
out of this world where none of the
component parts are going to look
sentiment Laden but that Engram there is
certainly going to carry a lot of
information and NLT kay also has this
tokenizer here which again I wrote I
released wrote the core of it that does
pretty well on these criteria here so if
you're working with social media data
I'd certainly argue for this one over
the treebank one for example and here's
what you might hope that the sentiment
aware one would do it would preserve the
username and the hash tag this one also
does the date which can be nice it gets
the URL and the emoticon and it
regularized this and I can quantify that
a little bit so I'm going to report on
some experiments and what I've done for
these experiments is just take a whole
mess of open table reviews and fit
classify simple like softmax classifier
to them with different amounts of
training data I'm always testing on
6,000 reviews but here it goes from 250
training texts to 6,000 the grey line is
whitespace tokenization the Green Line
is treebank
and the orange is sentiment aware and
this picture just shows that you get a
consistent boost on this sentiment
problem from choosing the sentiment
aware tokenizer and it's especially
large where you have relatively little
training data and that makes sense
because those are the situations where
you want to kind of impose as much of
your own bias on the data as you can
assuming it's a good bias because your
system doesn't have much to
work with whereas by the time you get to
6000 reviews these differences have been
minimized and just to round it out what
I did here to test robustness is trained
on opentable reviews again with from 250
to 6,000 but I tested out of domain so I
tested on IMDB reviews and it's the same
kind of picture the the performance is
more chaotic because of the out of
domain testing but I think pretty
consistently it's worthwhile to do the
sentiment aware tokenizing the orange
line basically strictly dominates the
others make sense questions or comments
about the tokenization stuff maybe I've
convinced you how about stemming people
ask me all the time about whether they
should be stemming their data so
stemming is heuristic Lee collapsing
words together by trimming off their
ends typically and the idea is that this
is helping you kind of collapse
morphological variance I think that's
what people are always imagining that it
will take like thinks thinking and smush
them together and to think and you'll
get like less sparsity in your data and
therefore more clarity there are three
common algorithms for doing this all in
ML TK the porter stemmer the lancaster
stemmer
and wordnet and my argument for you here
is that Porter and Lancaster destroyed
too many sentiment distinctions for you
to want to use them actually I think
that applies outside of sentiment the
word net stemmer on the other hand it
doesn't have these problems because it's
much more precise but then again you
might think it's not worthwhile when you
see exactly what it's doing porter
stemmer what i've done here is you know
the Harvard Enquirer lexicon that I
mentioned before it has categories for
positive and negative it writes them
without ease for some reason and what
I've done here is just give you a sample
of words that are different according to
their Harvard Enquirer sentiment but
that become the same token if you run
the porter stemmer so defense and
defensive become defense
extravagance and extravagant become
extravagant and affectation both become
effect you can see what's happening here
real sentiment distinctions are being
destroyed by this stemmer yeah tolerant
and tolerable taller temperance and
temper become both become temper here's
the argument for the Lancaster Samurai I
actually think this is even worse so
again positive and negative and when you
Lancaster stem them this is to the point
where like fill and filth both become
the same token or call and callous truth
and truant for some reason both become
TR you I think you were doing real
violence to your data quite generally
frankly by running these stammers but
for sentiment you're obviously going to
be losing a lot of important information
the word net stemmer is different so
what the word net stemmer is doing is
you need to give it a string in a part
of speech and then it will use its very
high precision lexicon to collapse them
down into what you might think of as a
base form so it does do the dream thing
for sentiment which is that like
exclaims exclaimed and exclaiming all
become the same word it doesn't do it
for noun forms and then on the flip side
it does collapse all comparative and
superlative variants of adjectives down
into their base form so it's doing it
with very high precision if it's not an
Alexa Kahn it's not going to do anything
to your word I think this is fine to do
it's just quite costly to do it at scale
it's probably not worth it in general
for collapsing these if you have
sufficient data and then for sentiment
you might regret actually having
combined together happy and happiest
because they're different in terms of
sentiment and just around this out I did
the same kind of experiment so this is
open table in domain testing 250 to 6000
reviews the sentiment aware tokenizer
beats both Porter and Lancaster
basically the idea there is that if you
take the sentiment tokenizer as your
kind of default baseline stemming is
only hurting you
maybe that's convincing and out of
domain
testing oh did I not include that it's
the same kind of picture when you do out
of domain testing make sense any
defenders of stemming wanna chime in
part of speech tagging oh yes
why don't you prefer to use these kind
of approaches for pre-processing versus
character level models you know that's a
great question one thing I'll say and
that you'll see a merge later in the
course is that the move to first of all
sequence models because they process all
these things in the context of what came
before and maybe after them and then
also analyzing done to the character
level has made these decisions in some
cases less important right so a lot of
these newer models can recover from a
bad tokenization scheme because of all
the contextual modeling that they're
doing overall I say this is a great
development because whatever you think
about my sentiment aware tokenizer even
it is probably not getting a perfect
read on exactly what the unit should be
but I would still say that it's probably
worth your while to start all these
systems in a reasonably good place
even if these differences are becoming
minimized yeah stemming relate to
misspelling the stammers are gonna do
what they do when you look at them
they're just basically huge regular
expression mappings so they don't care
about misspellings because they don't
actually even care about word identity
that much for newer methods misspellings
this kind of a related point if you have
distributed representations and you have
a common misspelling it's likely to have
a very similar representation to the one
that's spelled correctly in which case
those systems one of their selling
points is that they gracefully recover
from that stuff and may and therefore
reduce the need to like run a spell
checker as a pre-processing step
a lot and the other side of this is and
I think you can see that in this in
these plots like this makes it
especially clear I think the more data
you have the less these choices are
going to matter because the more your
system is going to be able to uncover or
recover from this bad starting point
it's when your data are sparse that
these choices really matter part of
speech tagging could help with sentiment
that's my first pitch here because there
are a number of cases in the English
lexicon where two words with a different
sentiment are distinguished only by
their part of speech so a rest as an
adjective like as in its arresting I
guess that's positive but a rest as a
verb according to the harbor Enquirer is
negative fine that's so that's a clear
case so it's a fine idea that's a
positive thing but to incur a fine
that's the noun version that's typically
negative so it might help you to create
distinctions by part of speech tagging
your data and essentially considering
every unigram to be a it's word form and
it's part of speech that's the first
pass here and that's some evidence for
it but even that sentiment distinctions
transcend part of speech here I've got a
bunch of cases from centi wordnet where
one in the same word with the same part
of speech has different sentiment so
mean could be that your mean is in you
know you're not nice to people but a
mean apple pie is a good apple pie or
something could smart that might be bad
and that means it hurts but somebody
being smart that's a positive thing
serious can obviously mean different
things depending on the context that's
something I experienced a lot in my life
a serious problem might be a good one or
a bad one depending on your perspective
and so forth so I don't have an answer
here except to say that even adding as
much pre-processing as you can think of
is not going to fully disambiguate the
words
in a way that aligns with sentiment that
makes sense I don't know that's a kind
of ambiguous thing here though like is
part of it is part of speech tagging
worth it is a pre-processing step for
sentiment it's not so clear to me that's
a kind of empirical question this is
really powerful though and again this is
a heuristic thing and an intuition that
we'll return to in the context of the
SST and this is just simple negation
marking so the the linguistic thing is
that you know all this these ways of
expressing negation and they obviously
kind of flip intuitively what the
sentiment is so I didn't enjoy it it's
probably negative whereas I enjoyed it
is positive I never enjoy it negative no
one enjoys it probably negative this is
an implicit negation here I have yet to
enjoy it that's like it might as well be
I don't enjoy it and I don't think I
will enjoy it that's a case where it's
probably negative sentiment and the
negation word is really far from the
associated thing that you want a treat
is negated which is the word enjoy early
on in the sentiment analysis literature
a few people have proposed a simple
heuristic method which is just basically
as you travel along if you encounter an
word that is negative according to some
lexicon that you've developed which
would include like in to not and never
and no one and so forth and you know
have a whole lexicon of them then you
just start marking all the tokens after
that negative word with underscore neg
up until maybe you hit like a comma or
saw or a period or some kind of
punctuation mark that tells you
heuristic aliy again that you've reached
the end of the scope of the negation so
what you're doing when you do that
appending of underscore neg is
essentially creating a separate token
you're saying that this word when it's
under negation is a different word than
when it's in a positive context and that
will help your system distinguish enjoy
an egg from enjoy positive and give your
system a big boost presumably so that's
a really easy pre-processing
that is basically just giving your
statistical model a chance to learn that
negation is important so here's kind of
what happens no one enjoys it would mark
everything after know with neg I don't
think I will enjoy it but I might if
you've got your algorithm set to stop at
a comma then it will stop that neg
marking at the end of what's intuitively
a clause boundary there and that's
probably good and here's a little bit of
evidence that this can really help so
got a full comparison gray is just
whitespace Green is treebank orange is
the plain sentiment aware tokenizer
and red is the sentiment aware tokenizer
with neg marking and that gives you a
consistent boosts all across these
levels of training data from 250 texts
to 6,000 and yeah even out of domain
this is a useful bias to have imposed
it's really giving your system a chance
to see that negation is powerful for
sentiment that makes sense
I just used a simple softmax classifier
I noted it down here which is just a
pretty good standard linear model and
that's really it it's just a bag of
words classifier it's just that one I've
done the neg marking this bag of words
has been kind of annotated in this
clever way excellent
that was it by way of general stuff now
we're gonna dive deep on the Stanford
sentiment tree Bank and this is perfect
timing because this will give us a
chance to talk about the code itself
under SS TDI and then you guys can leave
here actually ready to do the homework
if you want to and think about the
bake-off so the SSD project The
Associated paper is so true at all 2013
I was involved with this project this is
it was tremendously exciting at the time
for me it was the largest crowdsourcing
effort that I had ever been involved
with
I remember feeling somewhat nervous that
it would even work because we had people
annotating hundreds of thousands of
phrases in retrospect it looks kind of
small now Stanford has produced
annotated data sets that are vastly
larger than this but still it's an
impressive effort full code and data
release credit there goes to Richard
Souter I think you can still if you if
you visit that link you can play around
with the system it does wonderful
visualizations you can even offer to
give it new examples that it will then
learn from and then of course you can
use the code in lots of ways so a kind
of model for being open about your data
and your methods and your results it's a
sentence level corpus it has about
eleven thousand sentences and those
sentences are derived from a classic
sentiment data set that was released by
pang and Lee who are were really
pioneers in doing sentiment analysis and
I actually this paper at last year's
Knakal won the test of time award I
think the argument there is that they
really did set us off in the direction
of thinking seriously about sentiment in
its own right but also
as a great test bed for NLU models so it
starts from those Rotten Tomatoes
sentences which were labeled
naturalistically by their authors
because it's a review dataset but what
the SST project did is crowd-sourced
labeling not only those sentences but
every single phrase in all of the trees
that are contained in those sentences
it's a five way label thing actually
reviewers were given a slider bar and
then the labels were extracted and that
was justified on the grounds that by and
large people picked points on this
slider bar that were kind of consistent
with the labels that had been provided
so the result is a tree bank of
sentences that look like this here NLU
is enlightening these are real
predictions from the model all new test
cases I was very impressed at how well
this did it labeled NLU UNK but it still
got this right so you have labels for
all of these sub constituents so is is
neutral NLU is neutral enlightening is
positive and as a result of enlightening
being and being positive that projects
up the tree essentially this is an
example that i used to motivate right so
they said it would be great this is
really cool it knows that be great is
positive down here and it knows that
these things kind of aren't contributing
sentiment and the sentiment signal goes
pretty strongly up until the top here
but then it's diminished somehow and the
overall sentence is neutral that's the
prediction that I wanted from this
sentence because I feel like this
sentence alone does not tell us about
the author's bias it just reports
somebody else's perspective so you know
who knows what was happening up here to
cause this to emerge but it did and then
really cool they said it would be great
they were wrong it got that that was
negative and it got that that was
negative because it and it must know to
project things from the right more
strongly and so that they were wrong
over here with a one projected up to the
top even though this remains kind of
ambiguously neutral or positive it
didn't quite nail it they said it would
be great they were right I think right
must not have a
enough sentiment signal on its own but
at least it did figure out that this is
kind of just neutral here even though
there's positive positivity kind of
weakly expressed on both sides anyway so
I was impressed by the system but I
introduced these examples more to show
you the latent power of this particular
data resource this is kind of
unprecedented that you would have this
many labels and this kind of degree of
supervision for the individual examples
that's my intuition well my intuition as
a human is that you're right they said
it would be bad and they were wrong
should be positive it seems like a very
interesting stress test for the system
to see whether it got that right because
then it needs to know not only how to
balance the sentiment signals but kind
of how they've come together there are a
few different problems that you can
define on the SST there's a five-way
problem that's just using basically the
raw labels they go from very negative
negative neutral positive and very
positive and this is a breakdown for
train and dev there's a test set which
I'll return to and I've not shown the
statistics because I'm kind of trying to
keep it out of our view for now but it's
comparable to dev and I think this is
fine but there are two things you might
keep in mind about this version of the
problem so first intuitively if you say
think about sentiment strength
separating out polarity then for of
course is greater than 3 but 0 is
greater than 1 I think it's much more
natural to think about this as a kind of
two scales with neutral kind of unranked
with respect to the other two maybe that
doesn't bother you so much which should
bother you is that if you fit a standard
classifier to this kind of labeled data
set which has a ranking on its labels
then your classifier will be
conservative with respect to how well
you're actually doing because it will
regard a mistake between 0 and 1 as just
as severe as atom mistake between 0 and
4 whereas really you might think of
how you could get partial credit for
being close to the true answer and there
are models that will let you do that
even in the classification context like
involving ordinal regression or ordinal
classification but your model is
probably not doing that and so it's just
worth keeping in mind for this problem
that it's a little bit strange there are
two versions of the problem that make
more sense to me the first is this
ternary one which we're going to make a
lot of use of here you just group
together 0 & 1 as negative and 3 & 4 is
positive and 2 in the middle so you've
lost some sentiment distinctions but at
least with regard to the way the labels
were given it seems quite justified to
me and this one is nice because you keep
all of the data that you have available
there's another version of the problem
that is discussed a lot in the paper
alongside the 5 way one and this is a
binary problem where we simply drop out
the neutral category and then cluster
together 0 & 1 & 3 & 4 perfectly
respectable the only shame here is that
first of all in the world there's a lot
of neutral sentiment not everything a
sentiment Laden and the other is that we
had to drop out a lot of our data this
these statistics here are just for the
root level labels so they kind of ignore
all the labels that are down inside the
trees this is the all nodes task where
you actually try to predict all of the
labels on all the sub constituents you
get many more training instances of
course because some of these trees are
really big but you can define the same 3
problems in this way to kind of give an
equal footing to all different kinds of
models we're mostly not going to look at
this problem I have my only regard about
that it's just that this is one of the
more interesting aspects of the SST that
it has all this supervision and so I do
encourage you for projects and things to
think about how you might model the
fullness of this data set a good idea to
have two labels one for life prevalence
or one for this
do you want a valence oh absolutely
yes I mean that's kind of I mean the SST
doesn't have that kind of multi-way
label but my linguistic intuition my
kind of understanding of the psychology
of affection of affective states is that
they have many dimensions and you can
see that in one of those lexicons that
was released by victor Cooperman the
last one that i listed which has a few
different dimensions that they take is
kind of the true substrate for emotional
expression yeah I wish we could do it
here they've all been collapsed into a
single scale though all the ones like
reading yeah I guess like the verities
it's very so zero and four would be plus
emphatic and the rest would be minus
emphatic as a binary problem and then
you also have polarity which is positive
negative or neutral oh yeah no I take it
back that's a great idea
it's worth thinking about yeah and
certainly as a way of kind of seeing
what your model is learning it's
interesting to impose that distinction
other questions or comments
great okay let's dive into the actual
code this is perfect because I can cue
you up to start working productively so
SS TDI you'll have to get used to my
interfaces a little bit but my claim is
that having done that you'll be able to
work really productively because I
brought to get I've created a little
framework for you that should make you
quite nimble in terms of running
experiments first thing you just have
all these readers so you have trained
reader and dev reader and then each one
of them has this argument class funk and
there are basically three choices if you
leave that argument off it will give you
the five way problem if you set class
funk to ternary class problem it will
be positive neutral negative and also
binary class funk will give you just the
binary problem so these are nice
prepackaged ways for different getting
different views on the data the
notebooks explore all these different
problems and for the homework and the
bake-off we're gonna do the ternary one
because I think it makes a lot of sense
well this is easy and this is just kind
of set up you could paste this in and
follow along if you wanted SST is the
library the trees are already there for
you and your data distribution and then
these are the readers and maybe the only
other thing to mention is that each
reader you can think of as yielding tree
score pairs so I'll show you what the
trees are like in this in a second and
the scores are just strings as you would
expect given the way the labels work I
have a separate slide here on these tree
objects so they are NLT kay tree objects
up here you can see I created one from a
string this is just an illustration of
how to do that and if your notebook is
set up properly it will do this nice
thing of displaying them as pretty
intuitive trees so this is NLU is
amazing down at the bottom here for
subtree entry dot sub trees that's a
method that will cycle through all the
sub trees for you
just a really useful method to know
about and then up here this is basic
tree components so tree dot label will
give you the root level label for that
tree and then tree zero and tree one
will give you the left and right
children of that tree respectively
assuming they exist so you can see that
for this tree over here the left tree
the left child node is that subtree with
rooted at two and NLU and the right
subtree is the verb phrase is amazing
and then obviously that's recursive so
tree one zero would take you down to two
is and so forth there's a bunch of other
stuff you can do with these trees but in
my experience writing feature functions
these are the important components that
I needed if you think about writing a
function that's going to crawl around in
them this is kind of the nuts and bolts
okay we'll build up this framework in
three steps here the first is this
notion of a feature function and this is
a very simple example here this is a
kind of bag-of-words feature function
all the functions that you write all the
feature functions should up should take
a tree as input and so if you think back
to the readers write readers are
yielding tree score pairs it's gonna
operate on the left value of those pairs
the first one and it needs to return a
dictionary where the values in that
dictionary are counts or boolean z' and
they could be real valued as well so
like integers counts integers floats and
boolean z' and that's kind of the
contract right you can write any feature
function that will be any function of
individual trees as long as it returns a
dictionary and what I've done here is do
tree dot leaves to get all the just the
lexical items so I'm not really making
use of the tree structure and then
counter here just turns that list into a
dictionary where the elements have been
counted so that's a nice really quick
way to do a bag of words feature
function and I've shown you I created
that same tree I know U is amazing down
here
yuuna grams Phi of that tree yields this
dictionary that makes sense this is
something that you'll want to make a lot
of use of I'm assuming that part of your
bake-off and part of your homework will
be writing interesting feature functions
and they all they can do can do whatever
you want inside here as long as it's
tree to dictionary any questions about
that all right good
next step model wrappers so this
moonlight might look a little redundant
at first but bear with me you'll wanna
write functions that take as their input
XY pairs where X is your feature matrix
and Y is your vector of labels and what
those functions should do is fit a model
on that data it's a little supervised
training data and then return the fitted
model and that's all so here what I've
done is logistic regression from psych
it it's a good baseline model I said I
wanted the intercept feature like the
bias feature I specified solver and
multi class equals auto just so it
wouldn't issue its warnings it seems to
be in the habit now of issuing warnings
about those changing or something and
then I fit the model crucially you have
to remember to fit the model in here and
then it gets returned and again this
might look like just a tedious way of
calling the fit method on a model but as
you'll see by putting wrappers around
these things you can do a lot of other
stuff as part of this process without
changing your interface and for more
sophisticated models you might want to
do a bunch of sophisticated things
before you fit or as part of fitting and
then finally this brings it all together
SST dot experiment is like a Swiss Army
knife for running experiments I've given
it here with all of its default values
so that you can see at a quick glance
all the different things that you can do
but the point is you just point it to
your SST you give it a feature function
and a model wrapper and that's really
all that's required if you give SST
Experiment those three things then it
will train a model and run an assessment
on data that's separate from its
training data and it will give you a
report like this not only will it give
you a bunch of information about your
experiment encoded here but it will also
print out a classification report
and that's it right so you have to write
very little code in order to test your
feature function and/or your model
wrapper and then if you want to try out
different conditions like you can go in
here you could specify that your SS
reader was SS T dev reader and assess on
the development data you can change the
training size if you haven't specified
the SS reader if it's doing a random
split you can change the class function
you can even you can change the metric
you could turn off printing and I'll
return to this vectorize thing a bit
later but that's all kind of if you want
to do more nuanced experiments the thing
to keep in mind is that you can just
very quickly test your feature function
in your model wrapper and the other
thing I want to say is you'll see this
throughout for this entire unit and in
fact for many units in this course when
we see these classification reports we
are going to care mainly about the macro
average f1 score the reason for that is
we have slight class imbalances of
course for other problems the class and
balances can be really large and the
idea behind macro averaging is that we
care equally about all those classes now
I think that's justified at NLU and
sometimes the smallest classes are the
ones we care about the most micro
averaging would favor the really large
classes as would accuracy and weighted
average but macro is a kind of good
clean picture at how you're performing
across all the different classes despite
their size so keep that in mind as you
look at these reports you'll kind of
want a hillclimb on that value
SST experiment returns this thing here
unigram softmax experiment and that
contains a lot of information about your
experiment again I think this is part of
best practices like when you run an
evaluation you keep as much information
as you possibly can about what you did
every single time in my life that I've
decided to leave something out I've
regretted it because I wanted it later
and then I had to like retrain the whole
system or something
so what I've tried to do is package
together all the information that you
would need to study your models
performance and to test it on new data
and you can see that listed here you've
got the model the feature function the
data that it was trained on and the
assessment data and that's relevant if
you did a random split because this will
be the only way that you could recover
exactly what data you were using the
predictions the metric and the score and
then each one of these train and assess
data sets has the feature matrix the
labels the vectorizer which I'll return
to and the raw examples before feature
is a ssin I think that's really
important for kind of error analysis
because if you try to do error analysis
on x and y you're just staring at these
high dimensional feature representations
it's hard to know what's going on you as
a human unlike a machine learning model
would prefer to redraw examples and so
they're there for you as well so this
kind of brings it all together this is
on one slide here a complete experiment
testing bag of words on a logistic
regression model right so setup SST home
phi returns the dictionary counting the
leaves this is that simple fit model
thing and then experiment SST that
experiment just runs that I didn't show
it but it would print that report and
give you all your experiment information
that makes sense it's kind of like let's
do experiments without a lot of copy and
paste without a lot of like just
repeated cells that do basically the
same thing I'm hoping that in a notebook
you could use this to kind of
reconstruct or you know to conduct a
series of experiments and study them
without having a huge mess that's the
core of it let me say one more thing and
then actually we have time for a few
more but there's one more glimpse I want
to give you a glimpse about what's
happening under the hood because again
if you move outside of this framework
this is a nice thing to know in terms of
best practices so under the hood
when combining your data with your
feature function I have used the
scikit-learn z' feature extraction dict
vectorizer and i want to walk you
through why I'm doing that because I
think this is a really convenient
interface for doing all kinds of
problems and I've done it by way of
illustration so imagine my train
features up here are two dictionaries a
BBC and they each have their counts
associated with them that's like you
know if you write a feature function
mapping a tree to a dictionary what the
code internally is doing is applying
that feature function to all your
examples and creating exactly a list
like this so that happens under the hood
but what a machine learning model needs
or at least all the sidecut ones what
they need is a matrix they don't operate
on dictionaries they operate on matrices
that look just like the vector space
models you were building before right
strictly numerical data where the
columns are the meaningful units dict
vectorizer maps these lists of
dictionaries into such matrices so when
I call yeah I set up the vectorizer here
that fit transform is the idiom and
psych it on that list of dictionaries X
train here that's a matrix I put it
inside a data frame just so you could
see what had happened but under the hood
what it's really doing is operating on
an and P giving you an NP array but the
pandas dataframe is nice because you can
see that the keys in these dictionaries
have been mapped to columns and then
each example 0 and 1 we have the counts
of those features for that example
that's really good because for example a
failure mode for me before psychic came
along was that I would go by hand from
dictionaries to MP arrays and I would
get confused or have a bug about how the
columns aligned with my intuitive
features and then everything would get
screwed up and now I just trust the dick
vectorizer to do that so I as a human
and very happy to have these
dictionaries
I think it's an intuitive interface but
my machine learning models want this and
dick vectorizer
the bridge the third thing that's really
important about these dick vectorizer z'
the third problem they solve suppose I
have some test examples so here I have
the first one is a and it gets a count
of two abd with their counts but notice
that D is a feature that I never saw in
training if I call my vectorizer up here
and I just say transform on those test
features then I get X test and notice
that it's perfectly aligned with the
original space ABC and D has been
dropped out it's not part of my future
representations for my training data my
model will be unable to consume D and so
by calling transform I have just
gracefully solved the problem that D
would have imposed and also it's doing
the thing of aligning the columns and so
forth yeah it transformed it would have
just made a new column exactly yeah it
would have four and I would have lost
this correspondence with my original
problem yeah that yeah that's a great
point of contrast this is so important
because this is the way that you can
swiftly go from a train model and a
vectorizer you know process new data in
the way that you expect for your model
and get the desired results and again
this was an area where my code would
contain mistakes before and now it just
doesn't because of this dick vectorizer
but also it's really good to know about
and also it's good for you to know that
under the hood this is what happened
this is what's happening as we take your
feature functions and turn them into
something that a machine learning model
can consume excellent this has been a
lot of material the next phase of this
is I'm going to show you some methods
hyper parameter exploration and
classifier comparison but I propose to
save that for next time because this has
been a bunch of material and I think in
reviewing this section you're now pretty
well set up to start doing the homework
if you want so let me just review that
quickly and then we'll wrap up it's a
similar plot to the first homework and
bake-off
except now focused on the center at
Stanford sentiment treebank so what I've
done in this notebook is set you up and
give you a couple of baselines mainly
there I'm trying to document the
interfaces for you and I'll do more of
that next class but I've shown you how
to fit a softmax baseline and an RNN
classifier and do some error analysis
that might help you bootstrap to a
better system and then the homework
questions and there are just three the
first two involve a bit more programming
than the first one so they're they're
you know they're worth a bit more but
then you have this familiar pattern of
you develop your original system and
your original system will be one that
you enter into the second bake-off so
that's the overall plot for the bake-off
itself we're going to focus on the
ternary task as I said and basically
you're just going to try to do as well
as you possibly can on that task and in
this case I don't have to impose very
many rules you know before I didn't want
you to download external vectors and so
forth but in this case I feel like we
can just say do whatever you think is
best in terms of developing a good
solution for this problem if you want to
download vectors from the web that's
fine
if you want to download other people's
code that's also good the one note that
I have added is that it needs to be an
original system that you enter so you
can't just download someone's code and
retrain it and enter that you have to
make some kind of meaningful addition or
modification to that code but beyond
that anything goes except for the fact
of course that again here now we are
really on the honor system for the first
one I could withhold the test data but
in this situation the test data are just
the test distribution which you all have
in your data folder already so we're
completely on the honor system just like
we would be if we were publishing to do
all our development on the dev set and
only use the test set for that very
final phase when you actually submit
your system okay yeah I think that's it
you know the softmax baseline is the one
that I just showed you and I run the
experiment and here I'm using the dev
Reader
for development so this is the kind of
setup that you'll be defaulting to next
time I'll show you there's a few little
tweaks that you need to make to do deep
learning models in this framework but
it's really easy so I'll show that to
you next time giving you some tools for
error analysis and then finally the
homework problems the first one is like
write an original feature function the
second one is a kind of transition into
the world of deep learning and then the
third one is your original system that
makes sense all right it's a bit early
but I propose that we stop here next
time I'm going to finish this lecture
and then I hope to leave time for you to
do some of your own hacking so that I'm
sure that you leave here on Wednesday
feeling like you can complete the
homework the time window here is tighter
so that's really important